[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar immunodeficient mouse models
determine metastatic potential for nsclc
lines
i am kayleigh bach of labyrinths and
i'll be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by invigo to learn more please visit
invigo.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
i'd like to now welcome our speaker dr
mick d m edmonds excuse me
assistant professor and director genetic
and genomic sciences program at
university of alabama birmingham dr
edmonds you may now begin your
presentation
thank you kaylee and thank you for
everyone who's attending um it's a great
opportunity to present our work and the
collaboration that we've had for the
last year with individual um you know at
our core so what we're going to be
talking about today is we are an rna
biology lab and we release the goal of
our lab is to understand how rna
influence human health and the role of
rna in human pathophysiology and you
know
some of the problems that we seek to
address we use model systems for and
with multiple different model systems
but there are certain biological
processes that we can still only model
in vivo and that's what i'll be talking
about today i'll be talking about some
of our uh one of our projects in lung
cancer and and how some of these
different components of lung cancer
tumor growth and tumor metastasis can
still only be modeled even after 60
years of research can still only truly
be modeled in vevo and we've actually
found some pretty exciting tools that
have allowed us to do
studies which we haven't been able to do
recently and so with that i'll start my
talk
and so we all remember
our lectures in undergrad on rna and
being told there's three different types
of rna and those are mrna and trna and
ribosomal rna and how the human genome
and all its complexity and all its size
and all its bases only about five
percent of that or even less than that
codes for protein and the rest is junk
well we know that not to be true
and
sorry that advanced my slide and we know
that not to be true
because we know there are now
rnas that we didn't know exist
it existed 20 years ago and this list
that we published four years ago is is
out of date it was out of date six
months after we published it because
we're discovering more and more
non-coding genes that we didn't know
existed and now we're
tasked with the challenge of trying to
understand what their normal roles in
human physiology are and also what the
roles are in pathophysiology and i
highlighted here several different
non-coding rnas that my lab has spent
the last decade studying
and i will say given my background in
human health and training in pathology
departments we always start with the
patient we start with the patient we
identify
novel
genes novel rnas that are either
increased decreased shut off
in patient samples and we go in vitro
and we try to model what the role and
function of that different rna is in
vitro and then we go to the animal and
we develop a novel animal to see does
that non-coding rna actually have some
type of phenotype in a mouse model and
then we go back to the patient
i already see a comment the slide
advances aren't working
so let's go to this
bailey can you chime in real quick
he's only seen one of this
yep i'm gonna go ahead and here we go
there we go
perfect
outstanding thank you elizabeth
um technical difficulties technology you
think after two years you'd figure this
out
um
and so patient in vitro in vivo and i
think it's important after we
identifying these different mouse models
which is relevant for today's topics is
that we go back to our patient samples
and make sure the pathways the phenotype
whatever it is
that we observe in vivo we actually now
observe in the patients and so that's
the way my lab works and again
like i said
what we're going to be talking about as
cancer biology and so a lot of us are
familiar with the hallmarks of cancer
and i love this updated hallmarks of
metastasis and cancer biology uh
published by doug hurst and danny welch
about three years ago it's an
outstanding resource
and taking a new look at what we know
about neoplastic progression
knowing that indeed
we have normal cells they become
transform they grow uncontrollably they
begin to disseminate and they spread
across the body it's a multi-step
process a cascade of events that require
multiple different genetics and cell
types and
and and signaling processes to occur
and
we've every decade we learn more and
more about these processes and how
complicated they are and we add
different steps to it and as you can see
a lot of these steps with all the
different interactions with the micro
environment with other cell types and
with different
i would say physical processes that
takes place for metastasis and into
cancer to occur you can see that this is
really a complicated process that we
when we try to reconstruct we can come
up with different 3d models and
different organotrophic models but still
individual modeling is the best in my
opinion
way to go forward and approaching to
test these different biological
processes that's all today
i did it again
today i'll be talking about lung cancer
specifically and the reason for that is
lung cancer is the number one killer
number one cancer killer in united
states and worldwide and it dwarfs
i mean if you add a colorectal
pancreatic and breast cancer combined
lung cancer still eclipses those for the
total amount of cancer deaths
and so it's a huge problem societal
problem health problem but also another
major problem that makes
tackling this huge health concern a
challenge is that when our patients come
into our lung clinics
the majority of our patients already
have disseminated disease i would say
depending on what hospital you go to up
to 50
of your lung cancer patients are coming
in and being diagnosed with metastatic
disease and you can see patients with
metastatic disease have less than a five
percent chance of over five year overall
survival
what are some of the reasons for that
well there are many um but one of them
is that we don't know what the genetic
drivers are in lung cancer and again
this was published by bill powell and
katie hutchison 10 years ago in nature
this review looking at the different
oncogenic drivers and lung
adenocarcinoma because lung cancer is
really a spectrum of different cancers
there's adenocarcinoma there's there's
squamous carcinoma large cell and those
are your non-small cell lung cancers and
then you have small cell and
they're all very very much unique and i
would say adenocarcinoma is is our
probably best success story it's the
most common type of lung cancer and we
can only identify about half
of the of the patients identify a
genetic driver we've known about ras for
30 40 years activating mutations in our
ass and egfr but there's still this huge
piece of the pie
unknown for what's actually causing and
driving these and these tumors to grow
and
and metastasize and so that's an area
that my lab decided to focus on and to
fill in that circle and also identify
novel drivers but also understand how
these drivers work together because
obviously they don't work in isolation
and so a group of genes that we wanted
to study because as you can see in the
last slide a major emphasis has been
placed on coding genes and so we decided
to decide a non-coding gene specifically
i'll tell you talking about today is is
micrornas so what are micronesia these
are endogenous non-coding smaller main
molar molecules that regulate gene
expression they do that through a host
of different mechanisms and depends on
the microneed and this target mrna
but i'll finish this with it has tissue
specifically function
and what micrornas do these small rnas
is they're used as guides in these
rna-induced silencing complexes and
they're used by these
targeting complexes to bind to the
three-prime utr of messenger rnas
and when they do that they cause
degradation
and i would say what was one of the cool
things about microneed but also the
challenging things about studying
micronesia is that they don't just
target one meson journey migrate target
numerous mrnas in a given cell and
that mrna microneed targeting is cell
specific many times and so you could
have one microneed be oncogenic in one
context
and tumor suppressing in another
and that's what i'll be talking about
today
and so why are microneeds important in
human cancer because now after
20 years of research we know that
micrornas are involved in pretty much
every hallmark of of cancer
unregulated cell growth
evading the immune system go down the
list resistance to chemotherapeutics
microneeds have been shown to have very
very important functional roles and so
we decided to investigate these
as genetic drivers in human lung cancer
and we found a very very important micro
name mirror 31 that was over expressed
in human lung adenocarcinoma compared to
normal human lung and we found that over
half the patients over about 60 percent
of the patients in our lung clinic when
we did the study at the time of
vanderbilt had increased mere 31 levels
in their lung adenocarcinoma compared to
normal lung
interestingly when we looked at patient
tumors and we stratified them with
tumors that had high levels of meri31
and tumors at low levels of mere 31
there was a clear separation for
survival in that if you had a patient
had high levels of male 31 in their
primary lung tumor they actually had
almost two years less overall five years
survival that's pretty remarkable it's a
lot of misdrug opportunity treatments
it's a lot of miss birthdays and it's a
lot of missed life and so we felt like
clinically this was a really important
migraine and so then we went vitro let's
study to see if this has a role is it
just a biomarker which could be really
important or does it have a functional
role and as shown here on the left we
took mir-31 and we overexpressed it in a
non-transform normal
human lung epithelial cell the b2b cell
line and you can see by the black bar
these cells grow really slow over time
okay however when we add back in
exogenous mere 31 we actually
significantly increased growth and we've
done that in multiple normal cell lines
and multiple cancer cell lines we've
knocked it down over expressed it mere
31 and in lung adenocarcinoma cells is
very much a regulator of cell growth in
vitro
now when we take that and we want to
study that in vivo
to see well does do we see this in mice
and we we did several different
xenografts we took mirror 31 and we over
expressed it in lung adenocarcinoma cell
lines
that have
lower levels of mere 31 and sure enough
what do we see we see immuno 31 can also
promote the
growth of those lung cancer cells but
that's really getting to the question of
making a cancer worse the question that
we're really trying to test is
is is this a genetic driver chemier 31
which we see overexpressed in human lung
cancers community one actually
drive
lung oncogenesis and to do that we
developed a novel mouse model with
thomas handle
and what we were able to do is we were
able to over express mir-31
in the mouse lung epithelium by using
this mir-31 teton system and we used a
lung specific promoter the club cell
promoter and in the presence of
doxycycline in the mouse drinking water
we were able to overexpress meter 31 in
the mouse lung and specifically double
transgenic mice that had received
oxycycline in their drinking water
not in single transgenic wild type or
double transgenic mice not receiving
doxycycline very very nice specific
a specific a mouse model for us we
evaluated other tissues and we saw over
expression only in the mouse lung
but what happens when you overexpress
mere 31 the mouse long
we get tumors it was pretty remarkable
we see hyperplasia within two weeks
tumors sometimes we see small tumors at
two weeks within two months we start
seeing tumors in the mice four months
the tumors are larger these are all
adenomas
okay
and we're not seeing that in the single
transgenic or double transgenic control
mice and over time again to skip past
five years of work in time we actually
see carcinoma development and that and
it took about 18 months of treatment
which is about 65 in mouse years ages is
where we see the median age of lung
cancer incident and so very nice model
and we were able to show that mir-31 is
able to drive lung oncogenesis
and again
i think one of the reasons why this was
such a
big finding for our field and one of the
reviewers said it was beautiful animal
studies like you're able to show this in
animals because people in the in past
have been able to overexpress or knock
down near 31 in a lung cancer cell line
but it was really the powerful the
animal studies showing that mirror 31
over expression by itself in the lung
epithelia was able to drive
carcinogenesis
and again we were able to show multiple
things other than that which i don't
have time to go in today but mere 31
also synergized with k-ras lung
oncogenes and accelerated mice that had
oncogenic keras in their lung
and so like any study there's still a
lot of remaining questions
is mere 31 necessary for lung cancer
growth
does male 31 promote lung cancer
metastasis and what is the role of mere
31 and other lung cancer subtypes
and so to tackle that
remind everybody lung cancer is
i think
the reason why we have precision
medicine because we've known for a lot
for decades that one size doesn't fit
all when it comes to our patients in the
clinic one treatment will work for
adenocarcinoma but will not work for a
small cell and why is that it's because
if you look at the lung and you look at
the heterogeneity of the cell types
present in the lung you look at the
different
the different genetic drivers here on
the right and the lung they're
completely different and so yes you're
going to need a precision medicine
approach if you're going to target map
rash signaling it's going to be very
very important to do that in lung
adenocarcinoma but is that also true in
squamous cell
and so these are things to understand
and so knowing full well that mere 31
is oncogenic and lung and occurs and we
did that for a reason too
we know a lot of studies prior to r were
published in lung cancer meter 31 was
missed because what they have
essentially done is taken all these
different cancer types mush them
together and say hey what's up and
what's down and that's not really
appropriate because those are different
types
and so in this study we we knew that
mere 31 was over expressed in lung
adenocarcinoma and you can see here you
have these knight this is ish premier 31
it was a beautiful study
in patient tissue and you can see this
nice little red punctate staining which
is mere 31 in human
lung adenocarcinomas we also see really
nice staining in squamous carcinoma
adenocequamus
a little bit in the large cell
neurocrines and we don't really see it
in small cell lung cancers
and we can bring that back in a little
bit for the small cell
we're also able to see okay mir-31 is
over expressed
mrna is also over-expressed another way
to look at this in lung adenocarcinoma
which we've previously shown but also
squamous adenosine a little bit in large
cell neuroendocrines we don't really see
that in small cell and it actually looks
like it's down in these typical
carcinoids which are your slower growing
lung tumors which are pretty rare
and then in the cell line models we also
see that mere 31 is over-expressed in
compared to normal in the luads squamous
large cell and again not in the small
cell
well this is great because it looks like
mir-31 is overexpressed in the majority
of human lung cancers and so the next
step after we got these human patient
results is like let's go and look in
vitro
and
we
didn't see anything
we could
overexpress mere 31 in all these
different lung cancer cell types and
again these are non-adeno because we
know it has a very very specific
function in adenocarcinoma where it can
promote or suppress if we overexpress or
knock down but if we look at squamous
small cell large cell
we overexpress
we knocked down and we've looked at
every different type of growth assay and
we just didn't see a phenotype
and so
we were my grad student was ready to
drop the project it was very frustrating
we spent eight months on this i actually
did experiments because i thought
everyone in the lab was doing it wrong
we used mimic we used lentivirus
cell cycle analysis just everything you
could think of no change a repeatable no
change
and so
my student was done she's like i gotta
graduate i need to i need to publish and
so i must switch over to my other
project and i was like that's fine we
have really nice patient data let me
just
finish this up with an animal experiment
and again that goes back to my
experience working with danny welch in
his lab and looking at metastasis
suppressors and having a similar
experience where we have these really
really important
potent clinical metastasis suppressing
genes that have no phenotype in vitro
however when you go in vivo a powerful
suppression a powerful suppression or
promotion event and so
as you can see these data kind of speak
for themselves you know i'll start with
the upper right with the h520 squamous
carcinoma lung cancer cell line that was
the first cell line we picked and
we overexpressed meter 31 and we saw a
huge promotion of squamous cell
carcinoma xenograft tumor growth
not only in the volumes of the tumors
but the tumor weights it was remarkable
and so the project was alive again
and this again was using a cell line
that we actually you know we'll i'll get
to that a second but we were excited so
we knew we had a phenotype in vivo and
the next step was okay let's test other
cell lines let's test we're going to
obviously test more than one cell line
for each group
but we want to look at another squamous
carcinoma we want to look at large cell
you know we want to look at small cell
and really get a whole picture of what's
going on in in lung cancer permeate 31
expression and then we develop this
problem in that a lot of these cell
lines have not been tested in vivo
they've been published thousands of
times have been characterized for the
molecular and genetic events going on
inside of them um
which is a great resource but we have
found that a lot of these cell ends are
difficult to grow in vivo they won't
transplant the xenographs and so we
tested multiple different vendors um and
i will say that was kind of the
beginning of our relationship with
invigo reaching out to the sales reps
and saying hey what models do you have
and so
we were turned onto this this relatively
new mouse model called the r2 g2 mouse
model and we tried it and the majority
of our transplants worked and we
actually got subcutaneous um tumors
growing in these and as you can see we
were able to complete our studies and so
clearly mir-31 has a oncogenic effect
when we over express it in lung squamous
cells that's what you see on the top we
didn't really see any differences in
tumor volume in the large cells
we did see a difference when we did the
necropsies not in the volume but we did
see a bit of a difference in a little
bit of difference in the weight after
necropsy
and we really didn't see any difference
in the small cell which is fine and they
don't have to all behave the same these
are totally different cancers but
clearly mercury one has a strong
oncogenic tumor-promoting effect in the
squamous
but what was remarkable to us
is that when we're going through and
we're doing these knee crops again my
background is in pathology we're going
through with doing the necropsies and
the mice
in these mice that received these and
these any genographs that received these
subcutaneous tumor implants
which all took what we started seeing
are metastasis secondary metastasis in
the large cell we saw spontaneous
metastasis to lung when we over
expressed mu31 which we did not see in
the control group in small cell we
actually saw a significant increase in
liver metastases and then in squamous
metastases to the lung
so this was exciting because personally
have you been in this field for 15 years
i've never seen this for these lung
cancer cell lines they just in my hands
they have not metastasized just using
normal uh a thymic nude mice and so this
was a pretty exciting observation for us
which we'll follow up on the second part
of this talk but we were able to go
through and characterize
these different cell lines having near
31 overexpressed in them and we're able
to show that
in each one of these different
backgrounds whether it be squamous
whether it be a large cell or small cell
we over express mu31
the
transcriptional
and signaling backgrounds are totally
different mirror 31 has a different
function and again these are in human
cells that we've re-expressed mirror 31
or over express method they wanted and
looked at these different events whether
it be transcriptomics or also cell
signaling or kind of kind of analyses
and again going back let's validate that
in our animal models and so we were able
to go through in these animal tissues
and look at these different kinases or
mere 31 targets being affected and were
able to validate that yes indeed these
targets are being changed as a result of
neo31
and then finally we were able to go back
into patients and show that yes these
different mere 31 targets which affect
these different kinases and signaling
processes are direct targets in 31 and
yes they're decreased in patient tissues
and so this brings us full circle to
okay what what have we learned about
mere 31 and lung cancer in the last 15
years i would say it's a lot we have
gone from there be maybe
60 publications maybe
yeah it's around 60 publications of mere
31 in 2011 to over 2 500 now
and in that knowledge what have we
gained in our lab and in others well we
now know that mere 31
absolutely affects these pathways and
lung adenocarcinoma luad we know it
affects map kinase signaling we know
that it promotes lung adenocarcinoma
cell proliferation and metastasis and we
know it's
also important in squamous however the
pathways are absolutely different we see
different pathways affected and we see
different phenotypes we see differences
in proliferation and metastasis but not
in transformation which we need to test
a little bit more in large cell again
different pathways affected different
phenotype
and the same with small cell
and so i think one of the commonalities
that we have found in mere 31 which is a
future direction for us which we're not
going to talk about today but we feel
that mere 31 clearly has a role in
promoting lung cancer metastasis and we
have actually a lot of data to support
that we have a publication
coming on that but what's interesting to
us is that there are clearly different
mechanisms of function of music when the
primary tumor and near 31 and promoting
metastasis there are also different
functions
between these different subtypes of lung
cancer which make it a very exciting
gene to study
and so
going back to that
initial
third slide where we're talking about
lung cancer and the clinical challenges
of lung cancer and why it's so lethal a
major reason for that
is metastasis
and so to tackle that it's been
challenging because a lot of these
different lung cancer cell lines just
won't metastasize in your standard a
thymic nude mice a lot of your mouse
models
won't metastasize anything on an suv
background we have not seen metastasized
whether it be an oncogenic driver or
chemical carcinogen
i know of
one lung endocarcinoma model that we do
see metastasis and so that's what we're
working with but that's one model
as shown just in the last couple of
minutes using
some of these different backgrounds
these different immunocompetent
backgrounds specifically the r2 g2s
we have found that we actually get
spontaneous metastasis which is exciting
and so we did a pilot study and we tried
a couple different cell lines just
paranormal cell lines to see if we do
experimental metastasis which is an
injection of along human lung cancer
cells to the
lateral tail vein of
of immunocompromised mice those cells go
to the lung they colonize the lung and
they grow and we actually see them
growing
in the r2g2 mouse model and so we we
pitched we pitched this we went to
invigo and we said hey you have actually
a really cool tool
this is what we're seeing
we're seeing that when we take
humans with shown here human squamous
cells and we inject them into your r2
g2s we actually see metastasis in the
lung which is really exciting for us
because now we can actually test the
metastatic potential of these different
lung cancer cell lines plus or minus a
drug treatment plus or minus a gene that
we're studying and this really opens a
lot of doors for us but we were showing
them this
we were
again taking this in the route of a
collaboration because envigo has been
very helpful in this process to us
we said hey it'll be really cool because
we've tested a lot of different vendors
backgrounds for standard asymmetry mice
and and some of them we get transplants
with again same cell in our lab four
different vendors some of the different
lines grow
in certain backgrounds and a lot just
don't and so what we wanted to do is to
put forth a comprehensive study and
compare these different
immune competent background models from
one vendor being in vigo whether it be
your standard atomic nude mice uh the r2
g2 which we previously published on last
year which is very exciting for us and a
new mouse model the ndgs that just came
out early i think last year
and vigo's like hey do you want to test
these for expendable metastasis and i'm
like absolutely
and it really started this really fun
project which we've now wrapped up and
we are very close to a publication on
we're in the stages of submitting right
now
um and and we wanted to use an
experimental metastasis model and again
going back to those original slides when
you have cancer metastasis it's a
cascade of events right for the
origination of a primary tumor
the dissemination of the cells those
tumor cells making it into the tumor
vasculature or the the vasculature
spreading
getting arrested in a capillary bed
proliferating and invading out and in
starting the whole process of a
secondary tumor
and so we wanted to use experimental
metastasis and again that is bypassing
the first steps of metastasis we're
going to bypass a primary tumor and
we're going to put tumor cells right
into the circulation allow them to hone
and then
test whether or not they we we seed and
we wanted to look at the incidence of
metastasis for these different cell
lines um we wanted to look at the
tropism of metastasis we wanted to look
at the the size of metastasis was
possible we want to look at morphology
and then we want to do histology for all
these uh different tissues uh past gross
necropsies like actually do micro
metastasis and evaluations
i will say the cell lines that we tested
we looked at three different lung cancer
subtypes we looked at
let's get to it right here we look to
adenocarcinoma squamous and large cell
again your non-small cell lung cancer
subgroups
and
a lot of work but excitingly we had a
comprehensive analysis and so as you can
see we picked
two of the most commonly used cell lines
for each subtype and again this is in
our experience but we use the afo for
nines and the h 1993's for to represent
the lung adenocarcinomas we use the
h460s
in
h1915s for large cell carcinoma and then
we picked the h520s and lk2s for
squamous cell carcinoma
what we observed from these and again
this is from gross necropsies after six
weeks of television injections and i
believe this is a million cells per
mouse for each cell line
i'm talking that all being the methods
in the upcoming paper that we have
coming out
we clearly see that the r2 g2s
had the highest incidence
of metastases at time of necropsy in all
the different cell lines
and overall the dndgs the new line that
the new mouse model that we hadn't
worked with yet
actually was second followed by the
standard athemic nude mice and this
pattern really repeated what we've we've
seen in the past we don't really
normally see the a549s or the 1993s
metastasize in an experimental talent
metastasis using standard a thymic nude
mice
histologically
again now we're able to go deeper and
actually see metastases for the first
time micrometastases were we missed them
previously
and again what was exciting is that
whereas go back to the last line
where in the 1993s we saw about
nine about nine percent of the mice
having um experimentation still lungs um
just on the gross gross anatomy
that that's actually incorrect i have to
change it it's actually higher we
actually saw a lot more micro metastases
for the 1993s and again this will be
published
um relatively really soon
what's interesting too is that when we
started going through and looking
histologically we actually started
seeing metastases and tissues that we've
never seen before and i'll highlight you
to the large cell carcinomas we've never
seen ovarian metastases
in in
[Music]
in a mouse model before in the
experimental mouse model so this is very
exciting because again these different
secondary metastases are really
important i'll highlight also liver was
actually a common area that we saw
metastasis to in the r2 g2s for all
different cell lines
and liver metastasis is a huge clinical
problem in in patients with with
squamous carcinoma
so this is what we saw i hope you a
couple hours past breakfast
lots and lots of metastases and again
this was a million cells
and so again the nice thing about this
resource and i guess publication that we
have coming out is that we will tell you
how many cells what cells
all of our cells came from atcc so
they're going to be available to
everybody
and you'll be able to optimize your
studies and so again the r2 g2s these
lungs were covered in experimental
metastases you see these punctate
nodules all over the lungs the a59s we
did see some within 1893's lots with the
large cell lines and a few with the
squamous
we were able to go through and quantify
these and again go through and we fixed
the lungs and bones and we were able to
quantify these surface lung nodules and
again this trend of
increases
the biggest
the largest amount of surface lung
nodules were observed in the r2 g2 i
would say for the majority
of the cell lines okay so here are your
lung adenocarcinomas on the left your
a49s your h1993s in the middle you have
your large cells
and then on your right you have your
squamous cells and in each case we see
this
dosage effect of metastases where you go
from r2g2 bntgs aside and then your
standard athemic nude mice
we were able to go through and quantify
the micro metastases in each of these
and again those trends held true and it
increased our numbers
and then we were able to go through and
look at some of these
less common sites of metastasis now
i will hedge i will hedge it with less
common so when i say less common for the
liver the r2 g2 mice are i think are an
outstanding model for um
for liver metastases to study liver
metastases because uh pretty much all
the mice the majority of the mice were
able to get liver metastases after we
performed experimental metastasis
injections on them and the size of these
varied but definitely
they were there we also saw some kidney
and some adrenal metastases and ovary
metastases
and again our two g2 mice with the liver
metastases we're going through we're
following up again these are gross
gross macroscopic images and then again
histologically we go through and we're
able to quantify these different liver
metastases and these different non-small
cell cell lines
and i will say we also observed
um some tropism that we haven't seen
before and again this is primarily in
the r2 g2s we did not see in the
standard eight thymic mice adrenal gland
metastases lymph node metastasis bone
metastases and testicle metastases
so
in summary because i want to leave
plenty of time
for questions
in summary we performed a pretty
thorough analysis of experimental
metastases using
six different cell lines representing
three different subclasses of non-small
cell lung cancer and we conclude that in
large r2 g2
had the best transplants for
experimental metastasis the lung
followed by the bndgs and then
asymmetric nude mice and again these
were all provided by envigo
the tropism was largely lung liver and
kidneys and various other organs and
areas of the body but in that order
specifically and the metastatic size
was predominantly the largest in in the
r2g2 in the liver and the lungs
now with that i would love to
acknowledge my lab i would say that
bailey bailey davenport who's now at
school at university of florida in grad
school bailey did the majority she was a
technician at my time she did a majority
of these injections um well she did the
majority of the necropsies uh mackenzie
davenport actually did the majority of
the television injections mon vendor
student
did most of the necropsies and
pathological analyses for our lab and
then mara davis helped finish up a
simple the manuscript which we are about
ready to submit
and i also add too this is a
it's been a very fun collaboration it's
always
it's always fun to follow up on
observations from studies and that
really goes back to our our paper that
we're working on really the animal
studies were in 2018-19 when we're
trying to finish up some of the aviva
work on that mere 31 cancer research
paper that came out last summer
and seeing that hey these r2g2 mice are
great for transplants like they really
receive these lung cancer cell lines
which we have not been able to grow in
any other vendor
and and developing a really cool
relationship uh with our indigo reps and
with some of the indigo support staff
and be like hey what can we do where can
we take this next and then them saying
well where do you want to go with this
and that's pitching this idea and then
them supporting it and so we're looking
forward to publishing this resource i
think for the
metastasis lung cancer community to use
to look at because as i said these are
the cell lines we used
these are
the numbers we use and you can obviously
go through and manipulate to have more
or less depending on your time points
that you want to have and then what
types of manipulations you want to have
and so with that i would take your
questions
all right well thank you dr edmunds for
your informative presentation we will
now start the live q a portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen we'll answer as
many of your questions as we have time
for
all right so let's get started
our first question here asks how do the
immune cell profiles and
excuse me physiologic phenotype of the
r2 g2 compared to the other mouse
strains and the second part to this
question here in other words is the
immune component
of these mice largely responsible for
the results
that's a great question i would say yes
and i don't want to mess up the genetics
on the different mouse models and so i
would recommend going to in vivo's
website
to look at these different backgrounds
but that question we see a clear
relationship between the immune cells
present in that background of that
immunocompromised mice and the ability
for these different lung cancer cells to
grow so it's a great observation great
question
all right another great question here if
you wanted to study a lower number of
meds what would the or excuse me would
the b and d excuse me bndg be a good
model sorry about that
yeah that's a great question too and
again that's the whole point of this
resource that we're putting out there is
clearly the r2g2 so yes you could do
that you could say hey we have a study
where we want these mice to go longer
and and so we don't want to have to stop
the study of six weeks which we did for
a lot of our mice because the degree of
burden was so high i would say that the
ndgs would be a great mouse model for
that because they have
again i think they're more
immunocompetent there's more immune
cells present in that background
compared to the r2 g2s and so you could
do a lot more immune studies with that
and look at the interaction between the
microenvironment and the tumors and the
different types of immune cells present
um so yes that would be a great model to
use because you could go longer
and to be also a great model to use if
you want to see hey if we can accelerate
this right if we have a gene or it would
be a gene for our circumstances we have
a if we have a microneed that we think
accelerates oncogenesis we would put it
in that background because then the
background would be slow right the
wild-type bndgs and then it should
accelerate it i would also say i
wouldn't discount the r2g2s because we
know those take a transplant and i would
say if you want to have a lower number
of metastases just inject less i'd go
down to a quarter of a million or maybe
200 000 cells not a million
and that would buy you a lot more time
too
great thank you
all right
well it looks like we will go ahead and
wrap up with that last question there so
thank you again dr edmonds for your time
today in your important research we
would also like to thank laverts and our
sponsor invigo for underwriting today's
educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions questions we
do not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand and
laberts will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event until next time goodbye
you